معنا من عمان لواء فايزه دويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي لواء فايز حتى الان
كيف تقيم الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد والذي
تقول كياف انها تحقق بعض الاختراقات
يعني اولا الهجوم الاوكراني يجب ان يمر
بمراحل وهذه المراحل تعتمد على الخطه
الدفاعيه للجانب الروسي
الجانب الروسي قام واشار التقرير بايجاز
الى بناء ثلاثه خطوط دفاعيه كل خط من هذه
الخطوط يتكون من العديد من المكونات بدءا
من مواقع متقدمه حقول الغام خندق ضد
الدبابات موانع اسمنتيه اسنان التنين
مواقع دفاعيه معززه باسلحه ميم دال عمق
الخط يتراوح من تقريبا اربعه الى خمسه
كيلو متر ياتي فاصل عشرين كيلو متر ياتي
الخط الثاني الخط الثالث اذا نتحدث عن
تقريبا عمق 40 كيلومتر الى 45 كيلو متر
عمق الخطوط الدفاعيه القتال الان في الخط
الدفاعي الاول ولم يستطع
اجتيازه او احداث اختراقات في هذا الخط
تمكن من المناوره يمينا او يسارا من اجل
توسيع هذا الخرق وبالتالي نجح الجانب
الروسي في بناء الخطه الدفاعيه نجح الجانب
الاوكراني جزئيا في احداث اختراقات تصلح
ان تكون نقاط ارتكاز لتطوير العمليات
العسكريه لكن المرحله الاولى من الهجوم
المضاد حتى هذا اليوم لم تسجل انجازا
عملياتيا يعتد به كالسيطره على مدينه
كبيره او عقد مواصلات او تلال حاسمه لا
يزال انجازات تكتيكيه متواضعه لكن تراكميه
واذا ما حدث مفاجاه ما يمكن تطوير هذه
الهجمات لكن يبدو ان الجانب الروسي اجاد
في بناء الخط الدفاعي في الدفاع عن الخط
الدفاعي في توظيف الطائرات العموديه
لايقاع الخسائر بالقوات المهاجمه هل تقويه
الجانب الدفاعي الروسي وبهذا الشكل وعلى
امتداد الجبهه الشرقيه هو الذي دفع
الاوكرانيين الى طلب الاسلحه عاليه الدقه
وبعيده المدى
الان عندما نتحدث عن الخطوط الدفاعيه
اعتقد ان الاسلحه بعيده المدى ليس لها
ارتباط بمعركه الخطوط الدفاعيه لها ارتباط
بمعركه العمق ماء الان السؤال ما هي
الاهداف الدفاعيه الاهداف النهائيه
الاهداف النهائيه
شواطئ بحر ازوف
وبقيه المناطق ماريوطن وغيرها وطرق
الامداد وطرق الامداد والتزويد صواريخ
بعيده المدى عاليه الدقه من اجل قطع طرق
الامدادو تحدث عن ارسال سبعه تقريبا اربعه
الاف مدفع جديد
عن 700 منظومه دفاعيه الى بقيه الجبهه
السؤال كيف وصلت وكيف سمح لها ان تصل هنا
يبرز اهميه الطلب من اجل قطع طرق الامداد
وضرب التع زيزات التي تعزز القدرات
الدفاعيه للجانب الروسي اشكرك يا جزيلا
الشكر ضيفنا من عمان اللواء المتقاعد فايز
الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستر